everyone rails against the victim
mentality that seems to be sweeping
certain areas of the world I get it you
don't want your town or country or
species to go to hell because everyone
has forgotten how to take some
discomfort or deal with challenges in
life on another hand this rampant
fragility is your competitive Advantage
the bar has never been set lower a bit
of consistency a bit of intentionality a
bit of resilience and a gram of talent
will make you into an absolute killer I
also understand that you probably want
to raise other people up along with you
having a greatness stand on the
shoulders of the world's fragility may
seem exploitative and I love the idea of
not just improving yourself but changing
those around you for the better but
there's a limit your efforts are
multiplied by 10 times when building
with the right people by 0.01 times when
building with the wrong people if
someone refuses to alter their habits or
update their worldview or improve their
life by being given all of the tools and
encouragement they need by you then they
can stay where they are it is not your
job to drown Yourself by trying to keep
others afloat who don't want to change
humans don't mind hardship fact they
thrive on it what their mind is not
feeling necessary modern society has
perfected the art making people not feel
necessary that's Sebastian younger